>> Greg: HE TRADED COCAINE FOR
PAINT.
TALENTED HE AIN'T.
WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS HAVE
HELPED FORM AN ETHICS AGREEMENT
WITH THE ART GALLERY TO SELL
HUNTER BIDEN'S PAINTINGS.
THEY WON'T KNOW WHO BOUGHT THEM
OR IF THEY WERE SOLD BY THE
OUNCE.
THE NEW YORK GALLERY IS PRICING
THE PIECES BETWEEN 75 GRAND AND
HALF A MILLION.
OF COURSE THOSE HEFTY PRICES
HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH HIM
BEING THE PRESIDENT'S BRAT.
I WOULD SAY READ BETWEEN THE
LINES BUT HUNTER SNORTED THEM.
IT'S AS MUCH A COINCIDENCE THAT
HIS ART CAREER BEGAN WITH HIS
FATHER'S PRESIDENCY.
AS THE HACKED LAPTOP STORY WAS
KILLED.
KEEPING BIDDERS AND BUYERS
CONFIDENTIAL.
IF THE PAPERWORK IS IN CHINESE,
NO QUESTIONS ASKED.
THE WHOLE THING IS THE LATEST
EFFORT BY THE ADMINISTRATION TO
ADDRESS ABSURDLY LEGITIMATE
QUESTIONS ABOUT HUNTER MAKES
MONEY.
WHY HIS PAINTINGS HAVE TO BE
SMUGGLED ACROSS THE BORDER.
WHEN YOU HAVE A PRESIDENTIAL
FAMILY MEMBER SLINGING A PRODUCT
WITH A HIGHLY SUBJECTIVE VALUE,
THAT'S A PROBLEM.
THE FORMER HEAD OF THE OFFICE OF
GOVERNMENT ETHICS NOTED "BECAUSE
WE DON'T KNOW WHO'S PAYING FOR
THE ART AND WE DON'T KNOW FOR
SURE HUNTER BIDEN KNOWS, WE HAVE
NO WAY OF MONITORING WHETHER
PEOPLE ARE BUYING ACCESS TO THE
WHITE HOUSE."
ARE THEY BUYING ART THAT IS
CRUMMY TO LAUNDER HUNTER'S
MONEY?
DID HUNTER DRAW THE FLOWER TO
EXPLOIT HIS DAD'S POWER?
YOU'VE GOT TO WONDER WHAT HIS
DAD THINKS OF ALL OF IT.
>> LOOK, LOOK.
I'M GLAD HUNTER HAS FOUND A
HOBBY THAT CAN MAKE SOME MONEY
FOR A CHANGE.
I MEAN, LET'S FACE IT, HIS LAST
FEW HOBBIES, FAIRLY EXPENSIVE.
IF THE WHOLE THING IS ON THE UP
AND UP, IT'S BEAUTIFUL, MAN.
IT IS LIKE "THE PRICE IS RIGHT"
ONLY NO ONE KNOWS WHO'S BIDDING
AND THERE'S NO WAY TO OVERBID AN
INCENTIVE REFRIGERATOR YOU'RE
BETTING ON SOMETHING LOOKS LIKE
IT BELONGS ON REFRIGERATOR.
DON'T TELL ME THIS ISN'T A GREAT
COUNTRY, MAN.
>> Greg: THANK YOU, JOE.
DAGEN.
WHAT SOUNDS TO ME LIKE THE
WHITE HOUSE IS NOW RUNNING THE
ART GALLERY, RIGHT?
THE ART GALLERY HAS TO RUN ALL
OF THEIR DECISIONS TO THE
WHITE HOUSE SO THEY JUST OPENED
UP KIND OF A SATELLITE ART
GALLERY FOR HUNTER.
>> Greg: THAT'S WHERE I GO TO
BUY MY PANDA BEAR PAINTINGS THAT
ADORN MY BEDROOM WALLS.
>> Greg: BIG, GIANT EYES?
I LOVE PAINTINGS WERE ANIMALS
HAVE BIG, GIANT EYES.
>> Dagen: THEY HAVE A TEXTURAL
QUALITY.
THEY ARE FUZZY.
YOU CAN TOUCH THEM.
>> Greg: IT KEEPS MY VICTIMS
COMPANY.
>> Dagen: YOU CAN LAY THEM ON
THE GROUND AND SLEEP ON THEM.
HUNTER BIDEN CAN DO WHATEVER HE
WANTS AT A REASONABLE WAGE BUT
HE'S TRYING TO MAKE MONEY.
THESE PAINTINGS OF SOMEONE WHO
ACTUALLY KNOWS WHAT THE HELL HE
IS DOING.
HE CAN SELL PAINTINGS ON ETSY
FOR $40.
THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE WORTH.
NOT $500,000.
THIS IS LITERALLY THE EQUIVALENT
OF HIM COMING OUT AND SAYING I
AM GOING TO BE A 51-YEAR-OLD
WHITE RAP STAR AND I AM CHARGING
$200,000 TO PERFORM AT THIS
HEDGE FUND MANAGERS ARBOR DAY
PARTY.
>> Greg: PRACTICING A LOT IN
THE BATHROOM.
JOE, WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THE
ART IN GENERAL?
>> Joe: I'VE SEEN WALLPAPER
THAT I THOUGHT WAS BETTER THAN
THAT.
HUNTER BIDEN IS THE ONLY PERSON
I DON'T BLAME.
SEEMS LIKE WHENEVER HE GETS A
JOB, HE STARTS AT THE TOP, WHICH
IS PRETTY COOL.
SPENDING HALF A MILLION DOLLARS
ON A HUNTER BIDEN HIGH SCHOOL
CALIBER FLOWER PAINTING IS
LAUGHING LUDICROUS.
NO OFFENSE TO PEOPLE WHO HAD SEX
WITH MY FAVORITE RAPPER.
>> Greg: EIGHTH GRADE SCHOOL
PAINTING.
THIS IS WHAT KIDS DID.
YOU HAVE KIDS, BRIAN?
>> Brian: AS FAR AS I KNOW.
>> Greg: HE BLOWS THE PAINT AS
OPPOSED TO SNORTING IT.
IT'S WHAT KIDS DID BEFORE LAUGH
TIME.
>> Brian: FINGER PAINTING OR
BLOWING.
WHATEVER MAKES YOU HAPPIER.
IT'S AMAZING.
HUNTER BIDEN WAS IN THE NEWS
TWICE THIS WEEK.
FIRST FOR HIS PAINTINGS.
EVERYONE AGREES THEY SHOULD NOT
TELL ANYBODY WHO IT IS THAT'S
BUYING IT.
NUMBER TWO, THE OTHER STORY WAS
BY THE WAY, THERE'S A PICTURE OF
HIM WITH TWO OF THE RICHEST
PEOPLE IN THE WORLD AND HIS
FATHER FLEW THEM DOWN TOGETHER
TO MEET IN MEXICO.
THEY WOULD SET UP AN
INTERNATIONAL DEAL INVOLVING
BURISMA AND UKRAINE.
BUT LET'S FOCUS ON THE PAINTINGS
THAT GO FOR $500,000.
THIS IS THE CRAZIEST STORY.
HUNTER IS SAYING NO MATTER WHAT
I DO, NOTHING CAN EVER HAPPEN TO
ME AND NO ONE IS GOING TO ASK
JOE A TOUGH QUESTION SO WE HAVE
TO SIT HERE.
AS FAR AS THE HUNTER BIDEN
RUMORS GO, YOUR CIRCLE OF TRUST.
THIS IS AS FAR AS IT GOES.
IT'S CRAZY.
>> Greg: YOU SHOULD SEE THE
CIRCLE AFTERWARDS.
AIN'T NO TRUST IN THAT ONE.
DON'T KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING.
KAT.
HOW MUCH WOULD SOMEONE NEED TO
PAY YOU TO PUT THIS IN YOUR TINY
LITTLE APARTMENT.
>> Kat: IF I WAS GETTING PAID
FOR IT, THAT WOULD BE ONE THING
BUT I DON'T HAVE THOSE
ADVANTAGES.
YOU PLAY VIDEO GAMES LIKE
"MARIO KART," YOU GET POWER UPS.
STAR POWER, THUNDERBOLT.
IF LIFE WERE A VIDEO GAME THE
GREATEST POWER UP WOULD BE POWER
DAD.
IT LASTS FOREVER.
IF YOU FALL OFF, DOESN'T MATTER.
YOU CAN FALL INTO CRACK
ADDICTION AND YOU FALL INTO A
LUCRATIVE ART CAREER.
IF YOU HAVE THE POWER DAD, YOU
CAN DO ANYTHING YOU WANT BUT I
DON'T HAVE THAT.
I DON'T HAVE ENOUGH MONEY TO BUY
ONE OF THESE PIECES OF CRAP.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW WHO IS
REALLY PISSED?
AVENATTI.
HUNTER BROKE GUN LAWS, DRUG
LAWS.
POWER DAD.
AVENATTI A GREAT VIDEO GAME.
YOU SLEEP WITH THE HOOKER, YOU
GET 1,000 POINTS.
>> Brian: HOW MANY POINTS
WOULD YOU HAVE?
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: A JAB FROM THE
"FOX & FRIENDS" ANCHOR.
>> Brian: I HAVE A FIRST NAME.
>> Dagen: YOU ARE LIVING
VICARIOUSLY THROUGH JOE.
>> Greg: HUNTER HAS BEEN
PAINTING FOR OVER A YEAR.
>> Brian: I KID.
>> Greg: CORRECT THAT BECAUSE
IT'S EMBARRASSING WHEN PEOPLE
FROM THE MORNING SHOWS COME ON
AND DRAG US DOWN TO THEIR LEVEL.
>> Brian: CAN I POINT OUT, YOU
ASKED THE MORNING SHOW GUY.
YOU KEEP ASKING ME.
ASKING ME WHY I'M HERE.
IT'S THE WORST RELATIONSHIP
EVER.
I KEEP ON PLAYING INTO IT.
>> Kat: YOU KEEP COMING BACK!
"FOX NEWS @ NIGHT" AND WHAT'S MY
PROBLEM?
>> Kat: AT A CERTAIN POINT
YOU'VE GOT TO ASK YOURSELF.
>> Brian: I DID.
>> Greg: I ALWAYS HUG HIM AND